two saucers are good did i just drool
oh my god
what's happening to my body
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by matt damon he's an
academy award-winning actor he's been in
some of the most iconic films over the
last 25 years from goodwill hunting to
saving private ryan the bourne film
series and many more his latest though
is the tom mccarthy directed crime drama
stillwater which is set to release on
july 30th matt damon welcome to the show
thanks sean appreciate it i know that
you're a big cholula guy what's going
through your brain right now as you
prepare for the wing gauntlet today i
made the mistake of watching probably
too many of uh my colleagues do this and
so i think i went from being pretty
bullish about it to being i'm pretty i'm
i'm there's a humble man sitting before
you
uh my kids really wanted me to do this
too which i know is a theme a lot of a
lot of people say that but it was true
in my case too so
they want to see they want to see the
flop sweat so let's put on a show all
right
[Music]
it's terrific
so there's a store in williamsburg that
sells all these right yep shout out
heatonnessteetness.com.com.com
all right
well the classic hot sauce is fantastic
so far so good
[Music]
so your latest film stillwater recently
premiered to a five minute long standing
ovation at khan and in it you play an
oil rough neck from oklahoma
how did taking a road trip to the sooner
state eating at places like rey's
barbecue and then befriending real life
oil man kenny baker how did that help
you and tom mccarthy to shape the story
wow you knew about ray's barbecue
my place was fantastic um
that was really the key to everything
was going down there and i love this
script
and i just i read it and loved the
dynamics between all the characters and
totally believed it
but
the specificity of what a rough neck is
and what a rough neck does was
absolutely key to
creating this character so i and i
didn't know that whole world
we actually named the character bill
baker as kind of an homage to kenny
because his last name is baker kenny
took us around and went to these oil
rigs the way he walks the way he stands
the goatee and the wrap around glasses
all those specific details came from our
time down there and i think you know
they kind of met us the roughnecks kind
of met us with like some
understandable wariness like
hollywood yeah yeah what are you doing
like what are your intentions you know
what i mean are you here to poke fun at
us like what are you really doing but
once they realized
you know
that the script had all this compassion
and empathy for this character it was
about this guy and
um and that we were just trying to get
it right they they were awesome just
gave us unbelievable access and the
movie is what it is and that performance
is what it is and i'm really proud of it
but it's because it comes from those
guys
[Music]
oh that's delicious i would have both of
those in my house without a doubt
that's great
so i'm from illinois and my mom actually
worked for the u.s government's
anti-trust division and i actually
remember her working on the mark
whitaker case where i filmed the
informant
out of my own personal curiosity what
drew you to that story in that project
well
steven soderbergh
asked me and and incidentally asked me
to do it at a time in my career when it
looked like i was going that way
the porn identity hadn't come out um i
had a bunch of bombs
steven called me and i remember he told
me about it and i didn't realize he was
offering me to star in it i because
nobody had offered me a job in a while
and i said do you mean do you want me to
write this because i'm a writer also no
no i want you to scott burns is going to
write it i want you to star on it like i
couldn't believe it
anyway we sat on it for a number of
years until the timing worked out and we
shot it in 2008 and it's one of my
favorite things i've done and that case
was just incredible so i'm proud of the
movie we did
chomasa spicy habanero and man and
manzano and manzano chili hot sauce
intensely spicy just one drop hot sauce
well and this one's had a bath it has
okay that's fantastic
[Music]
that's delicious
big pepper but really good
i'm sorry i got to eat i got to kind of
eat all the wings because i saw bill
bird do that
um
boston thing boston strong
yeah he he did really well
so project green light offers a
fascinating insight into the chaos that
goes into making a movie
at what stage in the filmmaking process
are the stakes the highest like is
having a solid script the most essential
component to making a good movie or does
the sink or swim moment happen further
down the line well it can be both ways
you can have a solid script and you can
be adjusting it as you go along and
um
i mean the most hectic and
high pressure is in in production
because that's like when you're lighting
money on fire
um you know you've got everybody out
there you're on location somewhere it's
just really expensive pre-production
you can kind of hit pump the brakes a
little bit you can slow down there you
can you can work kind of
regular person work hours
that's got a little more than i thought
how would you in layman's terms explain
the internal calculus that goes on with
a studio when they're deciding whether
or not to finance a film like whether or
not it's worth the gamble
yeah well that's the key
word is gamble because it's always a
gamble right there's you're always it's
always a risk they try to mitigate the
risk by putting somebody who they think
is bankable quote unquote bankable in
the kind of inside baseball of it is
they have a list from what i understand
i don't know that it's like
they meet like the heads of the five
families and the godfather and talk
about it um or there's some secret list
but it does seem like you don't know if
you're on the list or not you just know
kind of based on how many offers you're
getting like i don't think i'm on the
list right now
and i think you kind of you know it's
like the premier league you get
relegated and you get promoted and you
kind of go back and forth
but it does seem like if you're on the
list in one place you're on the list in
all five
[Music]
and do you do this by a taste profile or
an actual heat profile i guess you have
the habanero measure on the side yeah so
it's going up it's all going to keep
going up but that's a good question
because we do try to mix up the sauces
because physiologically you'll react
differently to different peppers so it's
like delicious
maybe you'll have like a a pepper that
like lights your lips on fire like
scratches your throat or makes you sweat
in the back of your neck a little bit so
we try to mix those up so that it's like
a full just the walls are closing in on
you the enjoyment yeah that you got
there's three totally different things
that these wings can do to you
this is great
so i've heard you say that you take
every job based on the director and it
would seem that guiding philosophy has
served you well having worked with nine
different filmmakers over the course of
your career who've all won an oscar for
best picture
clint eastwood is notorious for always
going with the first take what was that
experience like as an actor on the set
of invictus well it was a little
terrifying because i was playing with
south african and that's a really hard
accent to do
if you think about what our tongue does
in an american accent it's like the
polar opposite in a south african
accident so it's like
if you say
i'll be right back
and think about what your tongue does
they say
i'll bit off bake
and it's like what the [ __ ] just
happened right
it was very hard to it's something that
just required a lot of practice and i've
treated it like a
like a job
and i i tested that theory on day day
one of shooting
we did the first take
it went pretty well but
clint says cut print check the gate
which means you know we're done here
we're going to move on and i said hey
boss you know maybe you think we get one
more and he just turned and he goes why
you want to waste everybody's time
all right okay we're done all right good
let's let's move on so uh so i'm glad i
put all that work in because i really
don't think i got more than one take
ever
and then you had the distinction of
working with francis ford coppola in the
movie the rainmaker what are some of the
unique things that you saw him do to
elevate a scene different tactics i read
something interesting about him putting
rocks in your shoes yeah yeah that was a
scene in which i was supposed to be
uncomfortable i was walking into a a
meeting and then the kind of the setup
is it's a long conference table and
there's like 15 really high-powered
lawyers led by jon voight on the other
side you know these formidable
people with this incredibly formidable
guy in the middle of them right and i'm
little rudy baylor with you know by
myself
on the other side of the conference
table and sort of walk into the room
francis uh put rocks in my shoes and
then just told me to walk normally
you just want to be uncomfortable and
try to act as comfortable as you can
because you don't want them to see how
uncomfortable you are so things like
that
all right matt are you ready to move on
halfway mark you're doing great thank
you this one's the ginger goat here in
the five spot the ginger goat
[Music]
the original glow the tom brady of hot
chocolate
that's interesting i like it it's got a
little uh little pineapple in it
sometimes they'll like kind of a little
fruit
that's nice
all right matt we have recrained segment
on our show called explain that gram
we'll do a deep dive on our guest
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context of course you don't
have an instagram you might be surprised
to learn this you still have plenty of
pictures on the internet so what we'll
do is we'll put the picture on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story and an all sports theme i love
when we can do that we have an all
sports theme for matt damon so let's
pull up the first picture
do you have a lasting memory from
sitting courtside at staples center for
game five of the 08 finals between the
celtics and lakers absolutely i have a
[ __ ] great memory of that game
these seats are next to the laker bench
so literally we sat down and and you
know the guys who work for the lakers
are looking to go you got to be kidding
me like they they gave them to you guys
like they were so like this is like this
is you know i'm gonna talk to patrick
they were they were they were ripping
about it but
this game we were down like 21 points it
was something incredible and sure enough
these guys they come back all the way
and it gets capped with paul pierce the
truth driving down the lane
like laying the ball in and it hits the
glass and by the time it hits the glass
it hasn't even gone through the hoop
phil jackson's up calling a timeout to
try to stop the bleeding and wahlberg
and i are like going absolutely crazy we
jump up and we're like
15 feet from phil jackson
and phil jackson turns and points at us
and he goes shut down and shut the [ __ ]
up
and i was like and were like
like like we made it into the celtics
lakers rivalry just as like bit players
but and also phil you know he's known
for being so zen yeah yeah not in that
moment no i mean it was like probably
one of the worst moments of his
professional career it was like oh it
was like god not this again but uh but
yeah man it was it was like
you know
it was it was funny it was a moment
in stillwater you attend a game at the
velodrome and i've seen you at formula
one events i've seen you at rugby
matches
what to you is the most memorable
sporting event that you've ever seen
internationally a great question the way
that people cheer in europe for soccer
is is awesome it's where like to any
american who's traveling abroad
and has the chance to like just get
tickets and get into a stadium it's
really really fun it's worth seeing
the craziest thing i've ever seen
without a doubt though is a soccer game
in argentina my wife's from argentina we
went to spend christmas there about 11
12 years ago her family's team boca
juniors which is a very popular team in
buenos aires is is in the this final
and i say to my uncle well to her uncle
you know
hey can we go can we go to this game
and he gets this very serious look on
his face and he's like
[Music]
we can go we can go he says in spanish
we can go he goes
no women no children
i was like what like i thought you know
i was gonna take the kids and we were
gonna go to go to the game yeah
well i saw why when we went because
we had to get through i think three
police barricades there was temporary
fencing with barbed wire put up i mean
it was just absolute madness and police
with riot gear outside and if this is
the is the the field
people were sitting here
and people were sitting here kind of
like as if in the two end zones what
would be end zones of our football and
there was nobody sitting
in the best seats right because that was
the distance that people could throw
things and hit each other
our team won the other team's fans are
filing out and the trophy presentation
finishes and i say to hector i'm like
you know should we go and he goes no we
still still
and it was because they needed time to
get out of the neighborhood
where the stadium was and you had to
give them like a 45 minute head start
and then when they did let us out they
actually held us in these temporary kind
of cages i was like what are we waiting
for now and they're like now they still
need five more minutes to clear
the neighborhood i mean it was
absolutely crazy like definitely the
craziest sporting event i've been to
teacup masala all right
oh
oh
it's the back of the throat a little bit
huh it's it's starting it's starting
here yeah
all right
well it's on now
wow
so i think a scenario lots of viewers
can relate to is is sitting on the couch
on a friday night going through the
streaming services cycling through the
movies and thinking to themselves
they're not making movies for me anymore
as somebody who's been intimately
involved in movie making for 30 years
what are the macro hollywood conditions
behind that sentiment
well so what happened was um
the dvd was a huge part of our business
of our revenue stream
and
technology has just made that uh
obsolete
and so the movies that that we used to
make
you could afford to not make all of your
money when it played in the theater
because you knew you had the dvd coming
behind the release and six months later
you'd get
all you know a whole nother chunk it
would be like reopening the movie almost
and when that went away
that changed the type of movies that
we could make
i did this movie behind the candelabra
when i talked to a studio executive who
explained it was a 25 million dollar
movie
i would have to put that much into
printing advertising right to market it
but we call pna so i'd have to put that
in pna so now i'm in 50 million dollars
i have to split everything i get with
the exhibitor right the people who own
the movie theaters
so
i would have to make a hundred million
dollars
before i
got into profit and and the idea of
making a hundred million dollars on a
story about like this love affair
between these two people
yeah i love everyone in the movie but so
that's a that's suddenly a massive
gamble in a way that it wasn't in the
1990s when they were making all those
kind of movies the kind of movies that i
loved and
and the kind of movies that were my
bread and butter
by the way these were all great these
first six so i'm starting to not be able
to feel my
my mouth too much
[Music]
yeah all right
[Music]
wow i feel like i'm gonna drop about two
pounds i'm gonna hit my catch weight
[Music]
that is [ __ ] hot man but having said
that it's delicious that's actually
really good there's some uh redeeming
culinary qualities in that one
i would buy all seven of these
i really would
that one's that one's hot yeah yeah
so when we had david arbor on the show
earlier this season he said i love that
guy for drama to translate on camera
that something real has to happen
between the actors yes is it true that
steven spielberg excluded you purposely
from the military training instead of
saving private ryan to create a real
resentment between the rest of the cast
and you that's totally true
um
i was such a young diligent actor i was
ready to go to boot camp and he said
absolutely not he goes you can train in
any way you want but i'm separating you
from the other guys they really did they
were totally resentful
every time they brought up boot camp
because i think it rained the whole time
i think they had a tough few days
there's a there's an internet rumor on
reddit that if you watch the famous
idiosyncrasy scene in goodwill hunting
that you can actually see a subtle
wobbling up and down because the camera
operator was laughing uncontrollably
right along with you and robin williams
confirm or deny on that
[Music]
i don't know we could check i wouldn't
be surprised robin made everybody laugh
i mean uncontrollably
and when he would see people's energy
flagging he would just launch into like
10 minutes of stand-up
he was the biggest
you know comedian in the world and actor
in the world and
that level of like
i don't know leadership kind of like an
attention and of love coming from him
was just like
well you know everybody was ready to
like
work for another 12 hours i mean he was
just amazing
fact or fiction you declined to
participate in the bourne conspiracy
video game because you wanted a game
that was more like missed
yeah yeah wow wow that's uh no i just
didn't want to do a kind of a
just like a first person shooter like it
offered me a bunch of money but it was
like if you could make it more i don't
know a little more thought had to go
into it or you know like missed i loved
that game so i was like you know more
like mist
and uh they were like no and they just
went and made it without me
the bomb this is the one yeah this is
[ __ ] me beyond insanity jesus
[Music]
why
i don't have a good answer to that
question
oh [ __ ] why
but going back in
ah [ __ ] it
i saw billy eilish go back down through
the rotation i was like wow baller
amazing she said high bar with that
episode
wow it's up into the nose that's that's
that's incredible
so my only real goal with this minor
internet celebrity is to use it to
infiltrate the inner inner sanctum of my
favorite sports teams the teams that i
rooted for growing up
do you have an all-time most treasured
13 year old matt damon would freak out
if you had this moment thinking about
your brushes with the red sox and
patriots over the years oh i've had so
many of those moments i went um
in 1999
the all-star game was at fenway park um
they let us out on the field
um
it's really [ __ ] hot um
[Music]
wow to have batting practice
and i hit the green monster off my dad
wow i think that like
i'd never need therapy in my life
john this is terrible
the other thing is that
it doesn't feel good in my stomach
either right spinning a little bit do
you want to do you want a gas pedal to
the next wing you want to slow it down
no no no whatever you you lead the way
man you're driving okay okay so this
next one is the scorpion disco
that sounds fun
oh god
[ __ ] man
nope
gronk spike on that wing no it's
terrible
just say shadow
this fall you reunite with your lifelong
friend and longtime collaborator ben
affleck for the historical drama the
last duel do you have an all-time
favorite scene in a movie that you've
shot with ben
there's a scene in goodwill hunting
where uh he tells me to get out of town
and
that was really cool because we worked
on that for
four or five years up to that point and
it was a big scene for him and
when he did it
did one take
and the first take and gus van sant the
director went that was great
um i think i have it
and ben was so shocked
because we've been
imagining this day for so long
well he looked at me and i was like
because he's right i think we got it he
kind of insisted on doing it again
so he did it only three times and i
can't i don't know what take gus used he
could have used any of them because they
were all great
but the look of bewilderment on his face
that this thing you'd been waiting so
long to do was like over in 20 minutes
um that was probably my favorite scene
all right matt damon
last dab
[Music]
oh i have a great spice store you want
to hear a funny spicy i'd love to hear a
spicy so doug lyman who directed uh the
born identity
um
he's a really funny guy and he um
he loves spice you should have him on
your show actually he's a great director
he'd be a very fun interview
we're shooting a commercial here in new
york
doug calls this indian place uh he goes
i tell people i want more spice on my
food and they never put enough and i
know you have great spice there i know
you have the hardcore stuff and i want
the hardcore stuff so you give me
everything you have
he goes i'm telling you i guarantee you
i will not
come back and complain
the guy says okay
doug goes
gets his lunch
oh god
that's gonna be too much yeah okay
and uh he gets his food he goes to his
trailer
he takes a uh
one bite
he goes to take another bite and
projectile violence
it's like that sometimes like it can be
like that just too much bites the guy
was like if you want the good [ __ ] here
you go okay so
well [ __ ] man all right
cheers cheers man thank you this was fun
what a ride
growth
i might throw up
i mean i won't do it on camera but
like the last three is really yeah tough
it's like they've done something in the
lining of my stomach
yeah my kids are gonna be so happy
but thankfully matt damon
we've reached the end of the gauntlet
and just one more cumbersome task before
we roll credits we've been very generous
in talking about your career in film
enlightening entertaining and we're
hoping to put a little bow on that here
as we close things out what would be
your answer to a cenophile who asked you
to name four matt damon movies on this
particular day under these bizarre
circumstances with your brain on fire
that best define your career in acting
there's sweat coming down my neck in
like actual drops
it's unbelievable
four so like my four favorite
performances
i'd say still stillwater is one of them
i'm really happy with it
goodwill hunting definitely
i love the informant well one really
early on called courage under fire which
was a supporting role but that kind of
did a lot for me
i don't know maybe
wow that is unbelievably hot sean
look at ripley
it crashly i am i hit the catch weight
like two sauces did i just drool
oh my god
what's happening to my body
uh look at you matt damon making it to
the finish line all before puking taking
on the wings of death sweat smoking wet
but just working through the wings bill
burr would be proud your kids are going
to be i did i listen i brought i brought
the boston like bill did i'm i'm i'm
proud of that he's i love that community
he's on my mount rushmore of comedians
so i i had to [ __ ] stand up and right
along
right along bill burr on the mount
rushmore of hot ones chisel in matt
damon's face taking on the wings of
death listen to the tail and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life nothing i'm
gonna try to recover from that i'm gonna
i feel like i need a shower
i mean i'm literally
if you knew what was happening on my
scalp right now
that's that's a new experience i mean i
feel like if someone just put a garden
hose over my head this is incredible
but thank you man sean this was totally
worth it mike
my kids are going to be thrilled
honestly we we love the show i can't
feel my tongue it feels like my tongue's
getting thicker
thank you guys
15 minutes to 45. yeah yeah yeah 45
check back in you're gonna be good to go
that was a baller move man you didn't
drink any water
yeah you know i just uh that's [ __ ]
amazing that's really that's [ __ ]
amazing
i cleared a whole picture and then they
went back and filled
don put more in that might be a record
well
i better get bender do it yeah pass the
word to ben
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a quick
reminder of the hot ones season 15
sauces are currently available at
heatness.com that's right heatness.com
to get your hands on the season 15 hot
sauces i know you're sitting there
you're wondering at home like oh it
can't be that hot i think they're
overdoing it they're exaggerating i've
had spicy before i can do it we'll put
it to the test
now available
heatness.comheatness.com to get your
hands on the season 15 hot sauces
be careful around the eyes